Instructor: If the
concept of a set still hasn't
set in, let's take an example
with brunch, because everyone
absolutely loves brunch. Let's
say it's a busy Sunday morning
at a restaurant and people are
coming in for brunch and they
want to put their name on the
list. We'll create a variable
called brunch, and that will be
a new set. Then as people start
coming in, we want to add them
to the list. We say brunch.add(
Wes), brunch.add(Sarah Simone).
Then we are ready to open. What
we're going to do is take the
values from this line and start
to use it. We'll say const line =
brunch.values(). Now, we're
working with this line here and
we could say, "All right, who's
up?" First one is line.next.
value(). Why do we call line.
next.value() against it? Because
line.next() is going to give us
the generator item, and value is
going to be the actual item from
our set. If I console.log
that, we should see...OK, Wes is
up. Then if we've got room for
another person, we'll just call
that same code again. All right,
Sarah is up. Now, where is
our set at right now? Let's take
a look. Brunch, Wes, Sarah,
Simon; but that doesn't make too
much sense. What about line?
Just Simone is actually left.
That's really interesting
because when you call next()
against this line, it will
remove itself from the set
iterator, whereas the set is
sort of the gold list of
everyone that has currently went
through it. Then people start
showing up. We've seated our
first couple customers and
people are showing up, so we can
just starting adding them to the
initial set. We'll say brunch.
add(). Notice how we're not
adding them to the line, we're
adding them to the initial set
here. Maybe Heather shows up,
and then maybe Snickers the dog
shows up for brunch. We can
just keep calling next() on it.
We can call it next(), next().
As we do that, people are being
seated. Wes, Sarah, Simone,
Heather, Snickers. Even
though I added these after the
fact of creating the set and
creating the line here, we can
still add people to the original
one, and the iterator is still
going to iterate on through to
them.